[Music]
tattoos have often been presented in
popular media as either marks of the
dangerous and deviant or trendy youth
fads
but while tattoo styles come and go and
their meaning has differed greatly
across cultures the practice is as old
as civilization itself
decorative skin markings have been
discovered in human remains all over the
world with the oldest found on a
Peruvian mummy dating back to 6000 BCE
but have you ever wondered how tattooing
really works you may know that we shed
our skin losing about 30 to 40,000 skin
cells per hour that's about a million
per day so how come the tattoo doesn't
gradually flake off along with them the
simple answer is that tattooing involves
getting pigment deeper into the skin
than the outermost layer that gets shed
throughout history
different cultures have used various
methods to accomplish this but the first
modern tattooing machine was modeled
after Thomas Edison's engraving machine
and ran on electricity tattooing
machines used today
insert tiny needles loaded with dye into
the skin at a frequency of 50 to 3,000
times per minute the needles punched
through the epidermis allowing ink to
seep deep into the dermis which is
composed of collagen fibers nerves
glands blood vessels and more every time
a needle penetrates it causes a wound
that alerts the body to begin the
inflammatory process calling immune
system cells to the wound site to begin
repairing the skin and it is this very
process that makes tattoos permanent
first specialized cells called
macrophages eat the invading material in
an attempt to clean up the inflammatory
mess as these cells travel through the
lymphatic system some of them are
carried back with a belly full of dye
into the lymph nodes while others remain
in the dermis with no way to dispose of
the pigment that dies inside them remain
visible through the skin some of the ink
particles are also suspended in the gel
like matrix of the dermis while others
are engulfed by
normal cells called fibroblasts
initially ink is deposited into the
epidermis as well but as the skin heals
the damaged epidermal cells are shed and
replaced by new dye free cells with the
topmost layer peeling off like a healing
sunburn blistering or crusting is not
typically seen with professional tattoos
and complete epidermal regeneration
requires two to four weeks during which
excess sun exposure and swimming should
be avoided to prevent fading dermal
cells however remain in place until they
die when they do they are taken up ink
and all by younger cells nearby so the
ink stays where it is but with time
tattoos do fade naturally as the body
reacts to the alien pigment particles
slowly breaking them down to be carried
off by the immune systems macrophages
ultraviolet radiation can also
contribute to this pigment breakdown
though it can be mitigated by the use of
sunblock
but since the dermal cells are
relatively stable much of the ink will
remain deep in the skin for a person's
whole life
but if tattoos are embedded in your skin
for life is there any way to erase them
technically yes today a laser is used to
penetrate the epidermis and blast apart
underlying pigment colors of various
wavelengths black being the easiest to
target the laser beam breaks the ink
globules into smaller particles that can
then be cleared away by the macrophages
but some color inks are harder to remove
than others and there could be
complications for this reason removing a
tattoo is still more difficult than
getting one but not impossible so a
single tattoo may not truly last forever
but tattoos have been around longer than
any existing culture and their
continuing popularity means that the art
of tattooing is here to stay
[Music]